we got to say I'm cool I will never say
it to you ever again
simple
like simple enough
like listen listen I didn't realize it
was so serious to you it is
before the show
it's insulting if you don't get it if it
wasn't insulting you would be calling
your mother that
why would I call my mom bro
that is ridiculous oh my gosh let me ask
the other lady
calling your mother anything other than
mum wouldn't that be like with
yeah
Auntie bro you know my auntie though oh
my God that is a problem that is a
problem that is a problem
listen let me just say this thing I
understand what I understand the respect
level for for older understand that and
as I said already I take you on board I
take accountability you said not to call
you bro because it's a respect thing
okay I take that on board I take that
out yeah but you're not my auntie bro so
at the end of the day you can say
whatever you want you know what like
what you're saying hear what you just
said to me hear what you just said to me
you are not my auntie broth so that
means that you can ask anybody on the
chat about elders and aunties especially
as an African yeah
at this point yeah
I've taken accountability and I told you
like yes the word bro will come out of
my mouth sometimes it's by accident
because that's just uncommon way I speak
it's not an insult I'm expressing to you
I'm telling you face to face that's why
I came on here I'm not scared bro
anytime
let's not do this
listen please
bro I need to say something to you
firstly okay I know she she I know she's
not your your mum and I know she's not
your aunt okay we know that however she
is your Elder
so you should respect her even us in our
culture we have our parents who have
their friends they're not our aunties
but we call them aunties Uncle out of
respect so we must have respect for our
elders and there's no ifs or buts about
it okay the second thing I want to say
to you because you you not keep making
it out like I'm triggered about the word
bro no I'm not I'm from the hood I was
raised in the hood we speak to each
other like that every single day bro bro
bro bro
when I was talking to you I was saying
bro bro I talk the same way okay so I
don't have a problem with the word bro
let's just be clear on that okay I'm
gonna tell you where I had the problem
with you okay where I have the problem
with you is is when I was sitting down I
was watching you addressing the other
females that were sitting down and the
way you was addressing them was in a
very rude and disrespectful way now it
might not be rude and disrespectful to
you yeah and it might be rude and not be
rude and disrespectful to them because
everyone has their own levels of what
they think what they what they were
tolerate and what they won't and what
they think is disrespectful what they've
done but when it comes to me
my levels are up there
okay
that No One's Gonna disrespect me in any
way shape or form never have never will
my dad always taught me that my dad
always put that in me and he's seen me
for my respect I will die for my respect
and I mean that literally literally I
would die for my respect okay because
I've always been like that and I'll
always be like that and handling I am
like that I wouldn't like to be any
other way okay now when I saw you
speaking to those two girls I sat there
and I thought to myself you know what
maybe I should get up and leave now
because if he speaks to me like that
it's going to go pink yeah because no
one's going to talk to me like that can
I ask you listen I'll let you talk let
me speak now okay let me speak all right
so then after speaking synonym the way
he spoke to them you started speaking to
Auntie and then you started
disrespecting her something about Africa
or whatever I never heard her say what
you said she said okay I don't know but
I never heard that with my ears so I
can't say she said it maybe she did
maybe Michael listen I'm listening to
you let me finish let's have respect for
each other let's not I'm gonna make what
happened last time happen again yeah
let's get away from that yeah so when I
was speaking to you and then you start
you know when you're speaking to her the
way you were speaking to her I was like
wow like she's she's an older woman that
could be like my aunt or my mum and the
way you're talking to her is bang out of
order and you shouldn't really speak to
her like that that started then I
started so first I saw you speaking to
the two girls then I saw you speaking to
her and then I thought okay
he best not speak to me like that I
thought maybe because you know the other
two girls and maybe you might know her
that maybe you can speak like that but
me you don't know me so I was thinking
probably he won't speak to me like that
anyway
I was waiting patiently okay and
everything you were saying Michael I was
agreeing with a lot of stuff that you
were saying me and you was on a kind of
the same and so it was me and Auntie
okay I was on you lots Flex right then
what happened was I was supposed to talk
they never let me talk they shot me down
then I let one person go in front of me
two people go in front of me three
people got in front of me and then I
said when that person finishes please
may I add on what I wanted to add on
from before okay then what you did
you jumped in next and I'm like
so I was like no like you know what I
was supposed to and then you you started
going what no bruh nah bro no bro you
talking too much did it
that you've never met me you don't know
nothing about me
and you're talking to me like that
I'm older than you I did not disrespect
you and it was my turn and you made it
out like I cut you off
when in fact you went in front of me
that's what I didn't like
and then when you spoke to me like that
that's when the fire I thought the fire
in my chest come up and I thought you
know what that is is I'm starting to get
heated and I know me I don't want to go
from zero to a thousand because when I
get like that I just see red there's no
stopping me I don't see nothing either
police can be standing there and I said
I won't see them I don't want to get
like that
okay that's what happened and then after
that Pearl's like no no no whatever
whatever she let you speak she gave you
that 30 seconds instead of giving it to
me she gave it to you and then you was
like oh do you know what I I forgot what
I was even gonna say and then I was like
cool okay then can I now say my part she
was like no no no cut me off in a very
very rude way yeah and then she was that
next question so basically you're trying
to make me feel like I'm insignificant
what I've got to say doesn't matter and
you're just disrespectful you're like
you don't do things like that
so that's where I had a problem with you
and then you're talking like I'm already
getting rolled up and then you're
talking saying whatever you're saying
yeah and then I'm getting even more
because you're laughing when somebody's
switching here the law the the worst
thing you can do is laugh because when
you're laughing it's like you're trying
to make me like I'm a clown and trust me
my bro I am not a clown I tell you that
now I am not I'm far from it
so all I ask of you is when you talk to
me if you talk to other people and they
accept it bear on them but when you're
speaking to me speak to me of respect
you can call me bro if you want if me
and you are on a cool level we can call
you bro bro cause whatever it's cool but
just talk to me with respect that's all
I'm asking I'm not these other girls do
you understand and the thing is people
are like oh she's so ghetto oh she's so
look at the end of the day I was born in
the ghetto I never chose to be born in
the ghetto I was raised with Savages I
never I never chose to be raised with
Savages okay but at least at least I
changed my life I went to college I went
to university university I've got my
degree I'm doing my music I've got
married happy say something you've gone
on for a long time can I please say
something please
respectfully go on
like all right I hear everything you're
saying yeah
I can only control what I do all right
and in everything you said you know what
looking back because I've watched that
video about five times today
yeah and yes you did wait for your turn
this is this is all I'm gonna talk about
what happened between me and you I don't
want to talk about what happened let's
talk about me and you right so
um was it you waited for your turn I
said something then the woman said
something
and then you wanted to say something
after I just wanted to rebuttal what
that woman said because there was a key
point I was gonna make yeah and up to
that point we have to be honest I hadn't
spoke that much if you watch any if you
watch the video back and if you watch
anybody's reaction videos because quite
a few people have done reaction videos
to that if you look if you look at it
objectively that why is you see King
riches hardly spoke up to that point
right and and also I am somebody that
does shows in that case I'm not just a
random guest bro like I apologize I
should not call you both see it just
comes out no it's fine it's fine you can
call me bro it's not a problem all right
cool all right cool so so basically like
I'm not a random guess I'm a part of
what is going on there so this is the
reason why Pearl will feel like yeah if
King riches has something to say
then it's more than likely it's going to
be something that should be said do you
know what I'm saying it wasn't it's not
necessarily A disrespect to you or we're
trying to be horrible to you or
something like that it wasn't like that
I was literally gonna make one point to
rebuttal her then and yes it was good
you was gonna have your say do you know
what I'm saying and up to that point
you'd spoke more than me and up to that
point auntie I spoke a lot
and you can ask anybody that watch that
video anyone has done reaction videos up
to on that video last night RT spot the
most up to that point
yeah and that's what the least okay to
the point where people in the chat were
saying oh King Richards is just waiting
to say something yeah and then okay boom
that's that that that is that is that
point yeah then the second the second
point is when you was trying to
interject because you'd wait your turn
and I understand that yeah I said hold
on bro hold on bro hold on bro that's
all I said no but explicit
yeah fair enough yeah but what I said to
you was hold on bro hold on bro you you
talked a lot that's the exact word
though but anyway go on
yeah but that's all I said to you and
then that's when you started getting
hurt
from where I come from me someone saying
hold on to you you talked a lot he's not
some mad disrespect
even we're on a podcast a podcast is
going to get Lively people are going to
talk loud people are going to talk over
each other that's what happens it's not
something that the next thing because
someone talks over you or something like
that now is threats of violence that's
that's I'm sorry that's just ridiculous
and I confirm I come from something
listen I'm not no nerdy I don't know
like obviously I don't know what you're
into or who you're with like cool I'm
that's your thing in it yeah but where I
come from like that is not a big thing
because you're saying we talk Lively I
do I'm a host I I have my own podcast
successful podcast and it's rising yeah
and we I moderate this kind of stuff all
the time that's gonna happen it doesn't
warrant threats or violence and I just
felt that that was ridiculous like at
the end of the day I didn't say I didn't
call you names I didn't I didn't
threaten you I didn't even stand up
hmm like the way you acted the way you
acted was like it was bruh like at the
end of the day I'm not even gonna say
nothing you just have to look at
yourself so for anyone to say that oh
yeah but anyone to say that oh yeah King
Richard King Richards was rude enough to
Warrant that bro like that's that's
weird
because I didn't even get up out of my
seat and I didn't call you any names at
all
I said bro and I said you talked you
talked to you you talked a lot that's
all I said and now all I'm hearing is
use disrespectful disrespectful
disrespectful is that really disrespect
on a podcast all right cool are you
finished now
can I speak now yeah yeah all right cool
um everyone who's in here who hasn't
seen the video please go back and watch
the video and watch the way he spoke to
me okay and and and you're gonna see for
yourself that he was very rude okay now
you may listen and see what they're
doing right now is rude because I'm
talking to you you're not even listening
to me when you spoke to me I looked at
you and I listened to you so please
don't disrespect me you're right you're
right I'll listen I'll look and listen
to you go on right so what I'm saying is
to you that may not be disrespectful
maybe you're used to speaking that way
yeah or maybe you guys are all right
with that now me I'm a rapper I've never
done a podcast that's my first podcast
I've ever done so I'm not used to that
stuff yeah and even though it's a
podcast it does not mean that anyone has
the right to speak in a disrespectful
way I don't care if it's a podcast okay
now you're saying that you wasn't rude
I'm telling you that you was rude you're
seeing me I'm a good person I've got a
good heart I don't violate people I
don't stop trouble and for me to feel
the way I felt you was rude
now you might not want to think that I'm
telling you you was rude I showed it to
my brother I showed it to my boy I
showed it to my cousin I showed it to my
friends and each and every single one of
them said to me my man was rude
yeah furthermore they said to me lucky
that we never come and we wasn't sitting
there
okay this is the thing
and then you can speak okay
right let me speak and then you can
speak because if you had a sister and
you were sitting with your sister and a
man spoke to your sister in a
disrespectful way you ain't gonna like
that okay anyway you're saying you
wasn't rude I'm saying you was rude
I didn't like the way you spoke to me
you disrespected me so I responded Yes
violence is not good but the way you try
to make it out it was like I said I'm
gonna murder you yeah when I said to you
I'll smoke you myself I wasn't talking
about murdering you what the does people
think I'm crazy I'm gonna murder you in
front of the body cameras in a podcast
listen I've never killed someone in my
life and and insha Allah may Allah never
make me kill someone in my life yeah
that's that's not something I want to do
in Islam if you save one life it's like
you save the whole of of the mankind you
take one life is that you took the whole
Souls of man of mankind so I'm not into
that so let me just make that clear so
when I said smoke you I didn't mean
shoot you or kill you when I said bodies
I wasn't talking to you I was talking to
Paul because she always had to go around
asking people because people are trying
to meet Black Ops
he's got how many bodies she dropped nah
it's not that deep well it's not that
deep now look